the success of Seoul in a bowl relies on
doing large numbers at only ten pounder
heads treater must fill the restaurant
is twice over brian ad and gavin have
got to get those platters flying down
those stairs but they're only just
peeling the last potatoes I'm gonna send
you down a tray to corn bread and soup
as a starter it's the first Wednesday
night ever they've had to turn customers
away slightly spicy sweet
just to bring onto the
you've got a 30 count is three they've
had a person join them so it's now
before it's already looking better but
tonight is got to be perfect
nice and clean okay come on
and for the first time this week Brian's
not smiling something well they found
please edit send away so now we're
looking for a for soup and a tree soup
for cornbread treat cornbread Gavin
you're taking care of the dessert yeah
the team is pulling together
communication is much much better good
job if they can keep it going we might
just pull this one off
I said they are stuffed it was delicious
all of the different flavors that go
with it fully satisfied I'm gonna take
them some dessert you see that Empty
Bowls and for that dessert lady
surprises all with his homemade pecan
pies battle beating any day you know any
day I've just 40 pence to make each
slice is 1/5 cheaper and ten times
tastier than the ones sherita's be
buying in things must be doing okay
because we've hardly seen her in the
kitchen all night now the pressures
really it's still not perfect Tay was
called away you stick that ticket on the
train no one touches it but the vibe up
here has definitely got more
professional can't quite believe I'm
saying this but I think Brides actually
breaking a sweat